e hoje o dia a gente vai conhecer a
praia que eu já clique em gostei
O Vencedor quem tá lendo não agora
[Música]
E aí galera mais um dia de novo vai
ficar trabalhando
mas tem que pagar viagem para verdade às
vezes
Eita
que
pega um
e
nem tudo mão
Você só não fica sozinho só porque você
corre atrás de gato não correndo atrás
de gato tá soltinha ali brincando mas
não sabe se comportar ele pede para
mandar em mim então para mudar então é a
pequenininha lá só para enrolar rapidão
a gente me conhecer né
e onde é que a Regina quer ir ó ó
[Música]
a
falar tomava tipo meu cachorrinho Hoje
nós estamos escutando Filipe Amorim vai
porrada o limite padrão achar por cima
se digita não lembro a
data é uma vez ai como é
[Música]
o canal do Sertão os bons em sabia que
eu tava tão eu adoro muito e tudo que
ele possa meu usuário
E aí
Oi Bruna tudo bem Eu Primeira vez
primeira vez dele na praia e
E aí
a dica do pote
eu
falei que o rei do pop
eu chego ele site
para dormir lá também avisei mas eu
mesmo neles meu beijo me leva lá somar o
tipo de baixo hoje me escutando Felipe a
loirinha
borra
[Música]
sabe o que é
E aí
E você continua de bola certo
então
[Música]
assim é
não há mensagens
[Música]
o
cala a boca Pedro que tá falando mal de
[Música]
mim
e falou que ele usa prata é porque o
Neymar Ele me disse que meu pescoço tudo
era de verdade eu falei eu tô mudando o
O
Régis
não não dá não vem não vem não é O que é
isso aí o que é isso aí é parece nada
Bolinha tá aguentando mais não viu tu tá
onde é bom
Olá pessoal demais não tá pulando
E aí
tô
falando com o
Henrique
[Música]
não sei
remédio que eu vou arrumar de você ó
Baião de polvo paçoca de carne com
batata palha de camarão rodízio ahah já
foi em
Baião de povo bata bastante até mais
farofa de carne de sol arroz de caril
de camarão isso aqui não cobrem galera
camarãozinho
delícia tá bonito
sempre foi
os otários melhor comida da minha vida é
São Paulo se mostra as coisas que não é
Boa tarde Dani foi feito aqui na tela
Café da Pata
por gente essa foi o passeio de hoje né
Ai meu Deus você é tão lindo que ela
corre atrás de gato no meio da rua tá
bom
gostei não você já curtiu tanto com a
gente a deu tanta raspada com a logo
mais a gente vai escolher alguém para
passar aqui encontrou Pinho
Pousada Tia vai para um açaí ali Machado
fechado né